the U.S intelligence official that comes
out on the record and says yes we have
aliens I'm not saying you have to
automatically believe that those are
aliens but I mean yeah it's probably
aliens it's so Advanced that our own
Pilots have to consider that it might be
aliens what else could that blur on the
screen be but aliens
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you before we play some of this
other stuff
I did want to address one other you know
I talked about the objections people
raise and there's the well this is
really a distraction I've talked about
why that's really a ridiculous Theory it
just is
uh maybe it's a misdirection and we're
trying to fool our adversaries which is
also a very frankly stupid Theory uh all
the respect to Michael Knowles based and
then there's the well I think really the
underlying actually faith-based
objections that people have that they
think they can't believe this
because it would somehow contradict
their religion and I think that's wrong
too
the nicest angel you have
there's another one also and this to me
for me has always been the most credible
objection which is that well just it
doesn't seem possible it doesn't seem
possible that any
you know what we know for sure if
there's if there's life out there in the
universe it's not in this solar system
so we could be pretty certain about that
uh it's certainly not intelligent life
in this solar system
laughs
so at a minimum it's in some other other
solar system
which means that it's trillions and
trillions miles away which means that in
order to get here it seems like you need
to be able to travel to speed of light
or faster and even if you could travel
with speed of light it also seems as
though it would take years and years to
get here even then potentially millions
of years even at the speed of light
depending on where they are and that
doesn't seem possible as far as we know
it's not
and so I think that's another objection
people have it just seems impossible
but seems is the operating word here it
seems impossible based on what we know
about the universe and based on our own
technology It seems impossible it seems
almost like magic okay it would have to
be magical but obviously if you were to
go back you know if you take someone
from the year 1470
and you bring them into year 2023 and
you bring them to an airport okay and
you let them watch the planes take off
to them that is they're going to think
they're looking at Magic they're gonna
assume that this is Supernatural it's a
supernatural event because based on
their understanding of things back in
the 1400s that's not possible so it
could be a similar thing here
technologically as far as we are from
someone in the 1470s
is how far potentially an advanced
civilization could be from us or even
farther it's just because it seems that
way to us doesn't mean that it actually
is well this first one is from Mexico
this is somewhere in Mexico somebody saw
something and here's what they saw let's
look at this one
[Music]
I think people always say it wait pause
for a second
the other thing that we hear is we live
in a modern society Information Age
everyone carries phones around in their
pockets everyone has cameras there for
in their pockets so why isn't there
footage of all this okay that is a
reasonable objection for something like
Bigfoot
why is it that we don't see Bigfoot on
camera and if we ever do see him on
camera it's always a camera that was
made in the 1800s like it's the camera
they use to take uh Battlefield pictures
at Antietam is what apparently they use
to take pictures of Bigfoot um because
Bigfoot it is actually not real
but with UFOs that's not a valid
objection because in fact there's lots
of footage that people have taken
uh quite compelling footage including
this so just keep on playing this one I
assume this is compelling I haven't even
seen it
that's how unbiased I am I'm going in
assuming it's compelling
oh there it is
see
aliens confirmed hey what is that
like some sort of
yeah it looks like a flying saucer what
does that mean is that music in the
background what is that
I could do without the trumpet in the
background what kind of music is that
they put with that
[Music]
you don't need to put music if you see a
UFO you don't need to put dramatic music
with it it's already pretty dramatic at
least at least to me that one okay you
see that video and you think well that
could be anything you know who knows
what that is and true I mean that could
be anything but it's the again you look
at the totality of the evidence there's
so many videos just like that
here's another one uh this is one I
remember
I remember hearing about this this is a
footage that I believe is a commercial
um aircraft the passengers on Commercial
aircraft a couple years ago
saw this go ahead and play this
okay what is that
[Music]
what the creepy music again we don't
need the creepy music
like we get it
okay this UFO up here next to a plane as
it
shocking passengers
impossible Maneuvers
yeah what is that it's a good question
does that look like any kind of
Technology you've ever heard of
if it is an alien spacecraft
hopefully they have better customer
service than most human Airlines this
this is how stupid we are I really I
hope to God that just incinerate us at
this point
it's a video of a UFO and you got to put
a little a little smarmy joke in there
well that is a UFO own a better customer
service
along with the creepy music which by the
way doesn't even match the joke what was
that what was that movie that came out a
couple years ago uh the don't look up
right
That was supposed to be a I never
watched it examination but a parable
about uh climate change
and I think it was in the movie of
Leonardo DiCaprio there's an asteroid
coming and the scientist is trying to
tell everyone there's an asteroid coming
but nobody cares because everyone's
stupid and distracted
people about no one caring about climate
change well it makes sense for nobody to
care about climate change
because there's no reason to really care
about that I think that that works as a
parable for UFOs
that's a movie that somebody should make
similar to don't look up but instead
we're being invaded by space aliens and
no one gives
it's like what about independence day
except no one cares
an entire city is blown off the face of
the Earth and no one cares which baby on
that given the state of our cities I
could sort of understand you wouldn't be
able to tell the difference like the
aliens come and they blow up Chicago and
uh if you got there a day later after it
was blown up and the aliens are gone you
wouldn't even know you wouldn't know
that it was blown up are you one of the
millions of American men and women
dealing with premature hair thinning and
hair loss or maybe you're scared about
inheriting that thinning look because it
runs in the family well finally there's
a real solution that delivers on its
promise without the harsh side effects
unwanted chemicals and unpleasant smells
probia Hair Care uses a safe natural
ingredient called procapital to
effectively Target the three main causes
of premature hair thinning and loss
provia supports healthy scalp
circulation and delivers nourishing
nutrients to strengthen hair follicles
and anchor them to your scalp provia
guarantees more hair on your head than
in the shower drain probably as
effective for men and women of any age
and safe uncolored treated and styled
hair provia Works guaranteed or 100 of
your money back it's that easy right now
new customers save over 50 off on
provia's introductory package at
proviahair.com Walsh YT see results for
yourself right now don't wait that's
probably a hair.com Walsh YT okay let's
go to clip the final clip clip 12. well
there's no sound to this there's another
Navy pilot
yeah these to me are the are the best
ones there's a lot of uh
smartphone footage people footage people
have gotten
on their own but when the Navy Pilots
see it and they get it on camera like
that and they release the footage
and they don't understand what they're
looking at
well it's a drone but you think they
don't know what a drone looks like you
think a Navy pilot doesn't know it
doesn't know a drone when they see one
so there it is there it is folks
all you need to know
we are not alone in the universe except
it
care about it
if you don't start caring about it I'm
just gonna have to keep talking about it
until you do care
uh anyway all right
talk to you tomorrow
[Music]
okay uh boys set the terror level at
Code Brown because I need to change my
pants
[Music]